do you ever wear Conan merchandise
around
wouldn't hurt to help out a friend
wouldn't
I I have the mug
I just don't carry it around enough
you're supposed to carry it I told you
to carry it yeah did you guys give out
t-shirts I I just know I got the popcorn
I don't know that we ever gave out
t-shirts I don't know why we gave out
popcorn at the talk show we gave out
popcorn for years I don't know why yes I
don't know we also think I called you
from I sent yeah because I got that
that's the ship why why did you do that
popcorn I was I listen I was at the very
top of the power structure I wasn't
aware of all the decisions that were
being made during the talk show so
I was not I never signed off on giving
away Chicago cheese popcorn that was not
a decision I made I was again did you
not get into the swag of did you not get
into the the hats and the t-shirt and
all that jazz I think um just thinking
today no literally today because I did a
talk show the other day and and the hats
is like I'm never gonna wear this hat
like why don't does nobody have a cool
hat I know it's a problem what is with
that that's a problems look like you're
gonna spend like you're getting ready to
go to Martha's Vineyard right but why
doesn't anyone have hats that look like
oh that's like a
a cool hat it's very hard to do it's
very hard to crack what do you mean it's
really hard to do I don't want to get
into all the specifics right but let's
just say that it's very difficult uh for
late night shows to get good
merchandising it just is when I do mine
I think it's a terrible problem that
this country needs to address well I'm
here to change it because I'm I'm gonna
do a talk show I've now I'm I've been
wanting to do a talk show since since I
was in my 20s but now it's not about me
it's about the hats you would have a
great hat I would have a great hat you
know you'd have you'd have a Justified
hat you'd have Raymond Givens hat that
that said uh the name of your talk show
on it because that's a you you you look
killer in that hat that's part of the
character I'm giving the guests cowboy
hats yes very expensive cowboy hats and
within weeks your show will be in the
red you'll be hemorrhaging money because
so the guests come on let me just it's a
whole fantasy here we booked it on the
show yeah we just need to take your head
measurement yeah before prepare you or
do it two ways you either get the head
measurements or you buy the hats and
then book for the hat sizes that you can
get so oh we've got a seven and a
quarter let's look out who's a seven and
a quarter John C Reilly John C Reilly
what's book him on the show is he
plugging anything no he's not we'll get
him in here because his head is gonna
fit the Hat we have
smart I've thought about all this stuff
most of my life and yet you're you
didn't have good swag on your show we've
already established that I thought about
it you've done nothing about it I'm
staring at a mug right now it just
occurs to me Conan O'Brien needs a
friend by the way it's kind of a funny
t-shirt yeah you know what I mean it is
a funny t-shirt yeah I don't recommend
you drinking out of that mug I'll just
tell you that much what if it said I
like Conan O'Brien needs a friend that's
a funny
that's a yeah this should be a better
t-shirt and on the back it says no
seriously
you keep looking over your shoulder
don't get the peanut guys I don't trust
your laugh you're just a you know you're
a very generous laugher I don't think
they just had to turn around to say did
that was that actually you know what I
mean
um I think your insecurities eat away at
you this may might make you a a better
actor but you have deep insecurities
um and Like a Knife whittles a piece of
wood your insecurities pair away at your
soul sharpening it and uh I think
anything I can do to trigger those
insecurities makes you a better artist
that's my theory okay